our theory is a more perfect union aims
to show that what unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us when
she'll see Hulbert came to New York on a
business trip she expected to say three
days but the 22 year old who was six
months pregnant suddenly went into labor
16 weeks early that was in June and she
is still in New York
Jericka Duncan shows us how Hobart is
getting by thanks to the kindness of
strangers
one pound nine ounces that's all baby
Rosalie weighed at birth and though tiny
she managed to stir up trouble for her
parents
Chelsea Hobart and Jacob Wallace what is
this ordeal been like it's been a roller
coaster I mean it's a beautiful thing
right but it's not how you imagined a
how they imagined it was full-term in
North Carolina where they just moved
from Alaska specifically to raise a
family we wanted to be in the south and
have like southern hospitality and raise
her and have her in a place where we
knew everybody was nice but doctors have
told the couple Rosalie needs to stay in
the neonatal intensive care unit at New
York's Mount Sinai Hospital until
October leaving the couple stranded with
no friends no family and no place to
stay
what was your opinion about New York
before all of this happened a lot of
people dirty
I guess people aren't it kind of rude
there it's an opinion that has quickly
changed and she told me her story I was
just floored after new mom Kim Caplan
met the couple in the hospital she set
out to help them she posted a message on
Facebook and a group for mothers in
Manhattan's Upper West Side hoping
others would want to help offers came
quickly Jenn ACOG nettie let Chelsey and
Jacob stay in her vacant three-bedroom
apartment rent-free it was a no-brainer
I was gonna sort of do whatever I could
to make sure that she had a safe place
to stay and she could focus on her
daughter and it didn't stop there so I
reached out to Jenna and said what if I
provide meals for the first two weeks
she'll come back from the hospital and
there'll be a hot meal waiting for her
ever
single day from from a diner in the
neighborhood a GoFundMe site was set up
and has so far raised more than twenty
thousand dollars for the couple for me
it's unfathomable having and the women
who pitched in for Chelsea say she's
helped them too by showing strength do I
think I would be able to exude the
enthusiasm and like zest for life that
she does I do not think so I think she
is just really an inspiration for us all
have you put yourself in her shoes and
thought about what that could have
looked like if that were you I can't
even imagine I mean I am probably just
start to cry I had a hard time with my
boys in the NICU for nine weeks and to
hear what you were going through it
really put me in my place in a sense I
have family I have friends I have a home
here that I can go to every night and
Chelsea hopes that one day when Rosalie
is old enough the story of her birth
will be an inspiration she's gonna feel
invincible and she's gonna do good to
the world because of the way she came
into it a little girl bringing love into
a world where some might least expect it
for CBS this morning
Jericka Duncan New York Chelsea and
Jacob chose Jenna cagnetti the woman
with the apartment to be Rosalie's
godmother though they have just known
her for a few weeks their doctor told
CBS news that the baby is thriving
you know you feel so vulnerable as a new
mom just to begin with yeah to be in a
city where you have no kin you have no
clothes and when your kid is in thank
you I mean my daughter spent I'm gonna
make you you know it's really scary so
tough stuff I'm glad our neighborhood
came through
well done